they came to the center of rio de
janeiro by
foot and even on piggyback to protest
against president jair bolsonaro
in his response to the covet 19 pandemic
the protesters blamed the president for
downplaying the virus
with thousands still dying every day and
for taking too long to start the
inoculation campaign
there were posters comparing bolsonaro
to adolf hitler
and accusing him of genocide carina
munoz
says the opposition has been avoiding
the streets
in a country with the world's second
largest covid19 death toll
that can do so no longer
we should all be at home keeping
ourselves safe but we've reached a point
where we can no longer remain silent
we have to show the world that we are
against bolsonaro's denialism
if we continue to keep quiet while he's
holding rallies all over brazil
it'll seem like brazilians are complicit
with his attitudes and we are
not last week bolsonaro led a motorbike
rally in rio de janeiro
gathering crowds and scorning the mask
he's on the campaign trail
and planning more of the same
his opponents say they felt compelled to
respond
but the organizers of saturday's
nationwide protest
insisted people wear their masks while
making their demands
although it wasn't just about the
pandemic
one man came out against bolsonaro and
in favor of a free palestine
people here are asking for many things
for better public education
for better public health for vaccines
they're also asking for illegal mining
to stop an indigenous
lands but what they all want in common
is president bolsonaro's
there were protests also in the capital
brasilia
and in hundreds of other brazilian
cities the impeachment they're demanding
seems unlikely for now but the
opposition is trying for a united front
against bolsonaro
to be ready for next year's presidential
elections
monika yanakev al-jazeera rio de janeiro